Charlotte hello
where you from Persia Utah yes the land
of Mormons yes the stereotype holds up
uh kind of in and out not really
strictly Mormon so I had the choice of
kind of going Church if I wanted to
unlike a lot of my friends who kind of
were not given a choice it was you know
you're under my house my roof you need
to go to church so I would luckily
didn't have parents that enforce that
rule yeah had a fairly normal childhood
you know I grew up in Utah rode horses
played softball with snowboarding skiing
a lot yeah nothing too out of the
ordinary for a girl growing up in rural
Utah do you think cam model yes and
content creator okay so do you think
that career choice was a reaction to
your um I think maybe I had a little bit
to do with growing up in a culture where
sex is very very suppressed and like
taboo and dirty and I kind of made me
more interested in it and maybe yeah
exactly it's and it's seen as very like
dirty thing you don't ever talk about
you know it's like between a man and a
woman a husband and a wife and that's it
it's just filthy in all their context
and so I guess I've always kind of been
intrigued by like the taboo or the you
know things that were outside of
societal norms and it kind of just
started as a way to make a little extra
money and you know I and it was a little
it was fun because it was something that
I'd like write about and whatnot but
then it became something that I actually
really enjoyed and wasn't really about
the money anymore yes yeah yeah that's
what I love about it you make your own
schedule I mean it does have pretty
rigid hours like you really need to put
the work in if you want to be a
successful full-time camp model video
creator you have to really really put
the hours in it doesn't like you can't
just do it here and there yeah you have
to make a schedule and you have to stick
to it or else you're not going to be
very successful
just one mm-hmm
a little over one the upsides are
definitely making your own schedule
I'm able to work from a safety in my own
home I'm able to just like interact with
people online I'm a bit of an introvert
anyway so that works out for me nicely
that I can just interact with people
online and if anyone's rude or anything
I can just block them you know just kick
them out and not have to deal with them
anymore which is lovely
yeah no diseases it's uh although you
know everybody should get tested anyway
but it's yeah I like that a lot of
aspects of it the only thing I don't
like is like I said before you have to
put a lot of hours into it you know to
be a successful can model you probably
need a cam at the very least like six
hours a day six days a week if you want
to be super successful you should do
like eight to 12 hours a day like it's
really a grind if you want to be like
very successful so yeah I just do it on
my laptop just set it up with the webcam
and when I live cam that's what I do and
I also make custom videos for my
customers so that's another thing that I
do the same thing just set up my camera
or my phone and film what they like a
lot of girlfriend experiences so your
personal life is this effect like
relationships you have um it has in the
past
it's either people are really turned off
by it find it really like you know Horry
[ __ ] threatening yeah whatever you
want to call it and on the other hand
people will be a little over fetish
sizee of it like oh my god it's so hot
that you're a cam girl you probably just
love sex once off all the time so that
those those are like the two extremes
but luckily I have found partners that
are normal about it you know let me do
my thing and we'll keep it separate from
the relationship so yeah there's
definitely it has in the past cause a
little bit hiccups but if someone is has
an issue with it I just want to drop
them I'm not gonna try to convince
somebody to like you know change their
mind it's like why what's the point so
but on the other hand if someone is a
little over fetish sizee of
I'm doing then I also kind of just drop
on because it's just kind of icky and is
there something do you think you're like
very very sexual or or you just like
pushing people's buttons or what is it
I'm definitely have a very high sex
drive and it was also I slowly learned
it was a good way to learn my own like
sexuality and like my own turn-ons
turn-offs and other people's fetishes
like I have learned so much about other
people's fetishes and what they're into
it's it's insane so yeah I get to learn
a lot about people and I learn about a
lot about myself and also get to try
kinky weird things you know that I
probably wouldn't even have thought of
on my own so that's another thing I
really like about it and you get
customers that if you coming back so
that's mostly what it is that's why you
want to be on there all the time because
you'll get those people who want to keep
coming back and keep seeing you and
build a connection with you and then you
you don't mostly I mean mostly being a
Camberley is like 10% sexuality sex
stuff and the rest is just like talking
about music books my day yeah I mean
these these people that come in my room
they really just want to know like they
just want to get to know you because if
they just want to go jerk off and go
watch porn and jerk off and get off and
whatever you know but when they come to
a cam model they're looking for a little
bit more intimacy a little bit more
connection and so yeah it's a it's very
little a little what I do is sex when
I'm camming it's yeah it's a lot of like
human connection what was this was the
strangest request you
like garbage like my garbage throw in
the mail and I was like what do you
think is in there you know it's like
nothing sexy it's like dog hair for my
vacuum and like what do you I don't know
what you thought would be in there I was
like I thought was super strange what do
you do you have plans for your future or
you go here I would like to try porn I
love camping but it can be quite
isolating just sitting in your room
alone on the computer for hours a day
weeks on end you know so I really am
interested in working with other people
getting into porn I've done a lot of
research on the industry and I think it
would be an incredibly interesting
industry to get involved in so I'm
definitely looking forward to that
trying that out thank you
nice to meet you